MARTIN OMANDER: My guest
today is Pascal Jaillon,
who leads the developer
program at the start up Magnet.
Pascal, welcome to the show.
PASCAL JAILLON: Thank you.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
Pascal, would you
tell us a bit about
the startup Magnet?
PASCAL JAILLON: Yes,
so Magnet offers
a suite of products
for developers
to build great mobile
applications-- apps that
take full advantage
of all of all
the powers of
those minicomputers
that we now carry
in our pockets.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yes, good.
So what Google Developer
products do you work with?
PASCAL JAILLON: So we develop
for Android, obviously.
And we use all the tools
that Google can provide,
from know the
Mini-SDKs, the older
versions, the IDEs, the
[? generators, ?] everything.
Nowadays, developers
don't really try,
or having anything to say about
the version or the platform
that the users will use for
the mobile applications.
So at Magnet, we make
sure we can develop apps
for all those devices
in the nature.
MARTIN OMANDER: So
I haven't heard you
say the word "platform" yet.
But I suspect that
the word will come up.
And I'm a developer, and
I think many developers
with me get a bit nervous
when we hear the word
"platform," because it entails
going to a new code base.
You don't know the and
weaknesses and strengths
of this new platform.
It's a bit scary, honestly,
for a developer to go
with something completely new.
How do you address those
concerns from developers?
PASCAL JAILLON:
Yeah, well totally.
People, developers, want
to try it first, right?
So the bigger the platform
you're building, the more,
actually, you have to cut that
into pieces, into components,
that can be actually tried
and used independently
from each other.
So that that's exactly
what we did at Magnet.
We are addressing
different pinpoints
that developers have, from
connectivity, to real time
messaging, to
remote persistence.
And each of those
pinpoints is addressed
to a different products.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, so a
developer can dip their toe in,
and use one or two of
these, without going
whole hog with your platform.
PASCAL JAILLON: That's right.
And it's very
important that they
can try it, play with it, for--
typically, our new messaging
solution, we are hosting
a version in the cloud,
so they can just
use it, and see how
it works before they
can decide to adopt it
in their own product.
MARTIN OMANDER: Building a good
developer experience is hard.
I mean, we try to do
it here at Google.
And you're doing it as well.
It must have taken
lot of iterations
before you had something
that was ready to ship,
I'm guessing.
PASCAL JAILLON: Absolutely.
And it was very important
for us to understand
how developers
actually work, how they
develop the mobile application.
So we need to understand
closely the way
they work to build your
product that actually addresses
the pinpoints.
So focusing on the key
pinpoint is important.
And then, in the case of
rest2mobile, the first product
that addresses the
connectivity, we
realized, to keep the
developers in the flow,
it was better to actually
build a plug-in for the IDEs
as opposed to perhaps a
competitive solution, where
using the web browser to
download the full SDK,
we wanted to do that
within their IDEs
to keep the developers
inside their IDEs
where they are productive,
and doing all the coding.
MARTIN OMANDER:
You mentioned IDEs.
Developers use many
different IDEs on Android.
How did you deal with that?
PASCAL JAILLON:
Right, so also, we
wanted to make
sure that they had
the same experience across
multiple IDEs, also on iOS,
on Xcode.
So we ended up
doing a lot of work,
more work than we
intended first.
But we've got IDEs for--
we picked Android Studio,
because that's the official--
I think-- by Google.
And as a bonus, we
got that to work
with IntelliJ, because it's
a [INAUDIBLE] code base.
But we also built
a command line tool
for automation,
and for developers
who are not in the IDE.
And we built another
plug-in for Xcode.
It was more work on our
side, but, all good.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
one for Eclipse.
PASCAL JAILLON: You
can use Eclipse.
But we don't have to a
full plug-in for Eclipse.
But our command line
tools helps developers
who are in Eclipse
to generate the code
in their mobile applications.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So where are seeing the most
Android developer interest?
Are people moving
to Android Studio?
Are they still on Eclipse?
PASCAL JAILLON:
We see the switch
happening to Android Studio.
It's a great IDE.
It works really well.
The experience is great.
They get a lot of the
feedback and the work
that was done with
IntelliJ IDEA,
so that's definitely
a great place
to start building
Android applications.
MARTIN OMANDER: When I
download this plug-in
from my [INAUDIBLE] and
install it in my IDE,
what happens then?
How does it help
me, as a developer?
PASCAL JAILLON: With this
first product-- again,
rest2mobile-- we want
to help the developer
build their connected apps--
to connect their mobile apps
to REST APIs, to REST services.
It's a little bit complicated.
You have to deal with remote
connection to a server.
You have to deal
with JSON payloads.
MARTIN OMANDER: For the network,
anything on the network--
it can time out.
PASCAL JAILLON: Exactly.
[? I'm ?] working with
some offline capabilities.
So we wanted to offer those
capabilities out of the box,
with a plug-in.
So we do code generation.
And I know that code generation
sometimes has a bad reputation.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
code generation.
When I hear that,
I get suspicious.
It will be code I can't touch.
Magic code that, if I
touch it, it'll break.
I can't easily regenerate it.
PASCAL JAILLON:
Yeah, and we wanted
to make sure that that was not
a concern for the developers.
So we generated the
best code we could,
made sure that the
code that ends up
being in your mobile
apps is as good as what
you would have done by yourself,
if that were written by hand.
But we take all the
burden out of your hands.
We create this
code for you, make
sure it's
[? unitest ?] friendly.
It comes with
[? unitest. ?] It's
refactoring friendly, something
that the app won't decompile
just once.
There is a full life cycle.
So being able to
refactor, to make changes,
that was super important,
and we addressed that
with our plug-in.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So when building for
the Android ecosystem,
what lessons have you learned?
And what experience
would you like
to share with other startups in
a similar position to you guys?
PASCAL JAILLON: So
definitely, Android
is more open than
iOS on the app side.
So that's, good because
there are more documents,
more documentation.
It's a bit easier for us to
build these kinds of plug-ins.
At the same time, there
are multiple IDEs,
as you said earlier.
So we had to address different
platforms, different IDEs,
and build for
different code base.
It was not the case on
the Xcode side, when
we built the plug-in for Xcode.
But at the same time, we
had much less documentation,
so we had to look at other--
like, Github projects,
and work with other projects
to understand how to that,
to offer the same experience
for other mobile developers.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you for coming
in here, Pascal,
and sharing your experiences
with us, and our viewers.
PASCAL JAILLON:
Thanks for having me.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]